en el último vídeo estuvimos trabajando
con el problema número 8 en el cual
concluimos que este nuevo estudiante
tenía que tener cero hermanos recuerdas
bueno pues realmente no estoy seguro si
se entendió de una manera adecuada el
problema porque llegue al límite de
tiempo y además se me ha ocurrido una
nueva forma de resolver este mismo
problema así que podemos tener dos
formas análogas de llegar a la misma
respuesta así que vamos a repasar lo
tenía aquí una cierta tabla de la
cantidad de hermanos y el número de
estudiantes y esto era en un kinder en
una escuela preescolar ok y decíamos que
tres de estos estudiantes tienen cero
hermanos seis estudiantes tienen un
hermano dos estudiantes tienen dos
hermanos y por último un estudiante
tiene tres hermanos ok y después nos
decían que ingresaba un nuevo estudiante
que no sabíamos cuántos hermanos tiene
pero que curiosamente el dato que nos
daban es que cuando entraba este nuevo
estudiante la mediana de los datos era
igual al promedio de los
ok creo que está aquí vamos bien esto es
justo lo que decía el problema pasado y
después en el problema pasado nos dimos
cuenta de que la mediana siempre era 1
no importaba cuál era la cantidad de
hermanos que tuviera el nuevo estudiante
después acabamos el promedio y con una
simple ecuación llegábamos a que x tiene
que ser cero por lo tanto este nuevo
estudiante tenía que tener cero hermanos
bueno pues la nueva forma que se me
ocurrió para resolver este problema se
basa en una cosa muy importante es muy
importante que tú entiendas que la
mediana es igual a 1 este dato es muy
importante que la mediana es igual a 1
no importa la cantidad de hermanos que
tenga y eso lo vimos con mucha calma en
el vídeo pasado primero pensamos que es
lo que pasa si este estudiante tiene 0
hermanos después pensamos qué es lo que
pasa si este estudiante tenía un hermano
después 2 y después 3 y nos dimos cuenta
que siempre el número que está en medio
es 1 sea cual sea la cantidad de
hermanos este nuevo estudiante el número
que está en medio de estos datos es 1
por lo tanto la mediana es 1
en lugar de hacer toda esta suma de aquí
qué te parece si pensamos en el promedio
del número de hermanos que había antes
de que llegara este nuevo estudiante
nosotros sabemos que antes de que
llegara este nuevo estudiante la mediana
era 1 cuando llega este nuevo estudiante
la mediana sigue siendo 1 y ahora vamos
a ver qué es lo que pasa cuando me tomo
el promedio de los datos antes de que
llegue el nuevo estudiante antes de que
llegue el nuevo estudiante así que para
eso déjenme hacer un poco de espacio
no se me ocurre quitar todo esto de aquí
esto de aquí lo voy a quitar y vamos a
ver si con este espacio es suficiente
voy a quitar esto de aquí y también voy
a quitar esto de aquí
imagínate que no sabemos la solución y
tenemos esto de aquí aquí tenemos esto
está acá y también aquí tenemos esto de
acá ok entonces lo que sí sabemos es que
la mediana dado la cantidad de hermanos
que tengas nuevo estudiante la mediana
sigue siendo uno bien ahora pensemos qué
es lo que va a pasar el promedio del
número de hermanos que tienen los
estudiantes de este salón de clase antes
de que llegue el nuevo estudiante pues
bueno vamos a tomarnos el promedio el
promedio
de tres veces 0 es decir 3 por 0 3 por 0
+ 6 por 16 por 1 hay 6 estudiantes que
tienen un hermano más 6 por 1 + 6 por 1
ya esto le voy a sumar más dos por dos
hay dos estudiantes que tienen dos
hermanos más dos por dos por dos más uno
por tres más uno por tres hay un
estudiante que tiene tres hermanos ya
esto lo voy a dividir entre la cantidad
de datos o dicho de otra manera entre la
cantidad de estudiantes que hay antes de
que llegue el nuevo estudiante que eran
12 entre 12 y cuántos esto pues bueno
vamos a ver 3 por 0 es 0 + 6 por unas
seis más dos por dos es cuatro más tres
por unas tres más tres todo esto
dividido entre 12 ok o dicho de otra
manera esto es lo mismo que 13 sobre dos
o que ahora lo que sí quiero que
recuerdes y esto sí es muy importante es
que la mediana con el nuevo integrante
con el nuevo estudiante es igual a 1
tanto lo que va a pasar con este
promedio es que le vamos a sumar la
cantidad de hermanos que tiene este
nuevo estudiante que por cierto habíamos
dicho que era x es decir nos vamos a
tomar 13 más la cantidad de hermanos que
tiene este nuevo estudiantes que son x
ya esto lo voy a dividir entre el número
de datos que hay ya con el nuevo
estudiante si antes había dos
estudiantes pues si ingresa uno nuevo
tenemos 13 estudiantes 13 estudiantes y
bueno nosotros sabemos que esto tiene
que ser igual a 1 porque la mediana
habíamos concluido que vale 1 y nos dice
que la mediana es igual al promedio
entonces esto es por la mediana esto es
por la mediana y esto es por el promedio
y esto es por el promedio por el
promedio de la nueva cantidad de datos
promedio ok y si nosotros tenemos 13 y
le sumamos algo y lo dividimos entre 13
si esto nos tiene que dar 14 le tenemos
que sumar
bueno pues 3 entre 13 es 1 por lo tanto
para sumarle algo y que nos dé 1 pues le
tendremos que sumar nada es decir que x
tiene que valer 0 que por cierto es lo
mismo que vemos concluido en el vídeo
pasado este nuevo estudiante debe de
tener cero hermanos
bueno pues creo que este es el problema
con la solución más larga que hemos
resuelto
problemas de ese arte es un problema que
nos hemos tardado muchos minutos en
resolverlo así que dejémoslo por un lado
y vamos al siguiente problema el
problema número 9 de esta sección número
3 de este examen número 5 así que
borremos esta pantalla y vamos a hacer
el problema número 9 que me dice lo
siguiente problema 9 dice si 2 x x menos
3 es igual a 8 si 2 x x menos 3
es igual a 8 lo que nos preguntan es
cuánto vale x menos 3 / x + 3 x menos 3
/ x + 3 guau esto está muy fácil porque
es una ecuación muy sencilla de resolver
vamos a despejar a x de esta ecuación
que tengo aquí ok para despejar la x
date cuenta que esto es lo mismo que
tener x 3 es igual am y este 2 lo voy a
pasar del otro lado dividiendo o voy a
dividir ambos lados de esta ecuación
entre 2 y me va a quedar que x menos 3
es igual a 4 ok que por cierto es el
valor que va a que arriba x menos 3 es
igual a 4 ahora cuánto vale x bueno pues
si sumo 3 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación que me va a quedar que x es
igual a 7
que x es igual a 7 ok entonces cuánto
vale x menos 3 x 3 / x 3 pues esto es lo
mismo que x menos 3 vale 4 esto de datos
y lo tenemos 4 / x + 3 x 3 es 73 lo cual
es 10 4 entre el 10 lo cual es dos
quintos y ya está
estas las respuestas de este problema
número 9 estaba muy sencilla que bueno
porque ya habíamos tenido un problema
número 8 bastante pesado un problema
número 10 y yo espero que me queda por
aquí problema número 10 dice cuando
tomamos el doble de un número y lo de
crecemos en 3
el resultado es 253 cuando tomamos el
doble de un número no voy a tomar el
doble de un número ya este número le voy
a poner a le voy a poner a 2 veces un
número a 2 program ya esto lo de
crecemos en 3 es decir a esto a 2 veces
un número le vamos a quitar 3
esto nos da de resultado 253 253 lo que
nos preguntamos cuál es ese número bueno
pues es una ecuación muy sencilla de
resolver 2 a menos 3 es igual a 253 creo
que lo más difícil de este problema era
plantearlo en una ecuación matemática
porque resolver esto ya no está tan
difíciles y sumó tres de ambos lados de
esta ecuación aquí voy a sumar 3 lekube
a sumar 3
entonces me va a quedar que 2 a éste y
éste se van 2 a es igual a 256 ok
liberar dividiendo todo entre 2 entre 2
y entre 2 me va a quedar que es igual a
256 entre 2 cuantos esto 256 entre 2 me
cabe una vez
y sobran 0 bajo el 5 me caben 2 2 por 2
4 y sobra uno bajo el 6
y digo 8 8 por 2 16 sólo en 0 es decir
que vale 128
vale 120 porque esto se va a confundir
borremos podemos poner acá vale 128 y
esta es la solución del problema número
10 muy bien
vayamos al siguiente problema el
problema número 11 déjenme borrar esto
de aquí y vamos a pasar al problema
número 11 ok y dice la producción de
julio de una compañía de zapatos
deportivos arrojó la siguiente tabla
ok pues hagamos la tabla tengo una dos
tres líneas tres líneas
horizontales 1
tres líneas horizontales por una dos
tres líneas verticales una a algo más o
menos así dos ok
y tres líneas horizontales y verticales
ok y qué datos me dan bueno me dicen que
tenemos dos tipos de zapatos los zapatos
blancos o no déjame cambiar la
herramienta los zapatos blancos ok y los
zapatos rojos y los zapatos rojos ok y
por otra parte me dicen que tengo dos
tipos de zapatos deportivos
tengo dos tipos de zapatos deportivos
los que están hechos para duelan los que
están hechos para duelan duele y los que
están hechos para pasto y los que están
hechos para pasto
pastor seguramente tú te estás
preguntando cuáles son los que están
hechos para duela pero bueno a mí me
gusta mucho jugar basquetbol y yo compro
zapatos para duela porque así me siento
mucho más ágil cuando juego basquetbol
ok pasto duela y al final me dan en
total el total total tengo zapatos
blancos rojos pasto duela y acá abajo
también tengo en total el total ok y
veamos qué datos me dan me dicen que
tengo 3600 zapatos blancos de duela 3600
3600 zapatos blancos de duala ok y tengo
1500 zapatos rojos de pasto 1500 zapatos
rojos de pasto ok y además me dicen que
tengo en total a 5500 zapatos de pasto
500 zapatos de pasto es decir tenis para
pasto y por último me dicen que el total
de los totales es decir que en total
vendimos 10.000 zapatos 10.000 zapatos
deportivos 10.000 tenis o zapatillas
deportivas como le quieras decir no
importa pero lo que sí sé es que
vendimos en total 10.000 de estos
productos ok y en que me dice el
problema con la información de la tabla
con la información de la tabla contesta
cuántos zapatos deportivos de color rojo
vendió la compañía en julio cuantos
zapatos deportivos de color rojo vendió
la compañía en julio es decir lo que
quiero es el total de la cantidad de
zapatos de color rojo es decir busco
esta casilla de aquí atrás lo que vamos
es tras esta casilla de aquí es más
déjenme ponerla con otro color vamos a
ponerla con un color más tenue atrás lo
que voy a este hombre este total que
tengo aquí lo que quiero sacar es
de la cantidad de zapatos rojos de los
tenis rojos que vendí en este mes de
julio
ok pues como lo sacamos a si quiero esto
pues qué datos puede utilizar bueno se
me ocurre decir que ok podemos sacar la
cantidad de zapatos de duela que
vendimos en total fíjate bien si en
total vendimos 10.000 zapatos en total
vendimos 10 mil zapatos y de esos 10 mil
zapatos 5500 fueron para pasto cuántos
eran para duela bueno pues para duela
eran lo que nos falta para llegar a 10
mil zapatos si nosotros empezamos en
5500 es decir nos faltan 4000 4500 4500
zapatos de duela se vendieron en el mes
de julio pero nosotros sabemos por otra
parte que de estos zapatos de duela que
se vendieron total de estos 4 mil 500 3
mil 600 eran zapatos blancos eran
zapatos deportivos blancos
cuántos zapatos deportivos rojos
vendimos bueno pues esencialmente lo que
hay que tomarnos es 4500 ya esto
restarle pues los 3600 que tenemos de
color blanco los 3600 y esto me da a 0
06 para 59 de que bajó 1 en me queda 4
menos 40 es decir que vendimos 900
zapatos de color rojo para duela ok y si
ya tengo 900 zapatos de cuero rojo para
duela y además tengo 1500 zapatos rojos
que nos sirven para el pastor entonces
cuántos zapatos rojos en total vendimos
ya estamos al lado de la respuesta lo
único que hay que hacer es sumar estos 2
900 más 1500
esto me da 0 0 y 9 más 15 es lo mismo
que 24 24 es decir 2.400 zapatos de
color rojo se vendieron en total la
respuesta es 2400 zapatos de color
zapatos de color rojo y ya está esta es
la respuesta y ya hemos acabado el
problema número 11 así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima